who's excited for Paw Patrol
Kim Kardashian celebrated her new
animated film Paw Patrol the movie with
a special screening for her kids yes the
40 year old reality star and Mama four
took her kids eight-year-old North
five-year-old Saint three-year-old
Chicago and two-year-old Psalm along
with a few of their friends to a private
screening at a movie theater on Thursday
it's always so much fun naturally she
documented the whole thing on her
Instagram story you guys I am at the
premiere of Paw Patrol the first ever
Paw Patrol movie look what is set up
check out the special swag she brought
for everyone in attendance which
included Paw Patrol toys and full-size
stuffed animals of her character the
poodle Dolores
please this scrawny little purse pup is
gonna pull a jailbreak can I see Dolores
good morning oh my gosh Dolores
[Music]
is here Dolores is here
you guys this is so exciting mommy yeah
at the store I saw here I saw your
little plushie of you you did of yours
yeah oh my gosh how cool I saw a little
plushie of you how cute is that thank
you of course a room full of excited
kiddos it got a bit chaotic we have some
amazing party favors for everyone hey
Sammy it's okay you can take it
they are acting wild in here but Kim who
shares her children with her ex Kanye
West seemed super excited to share the
whole experience with her little ones
I'm holding you you're holding me yes
you are the kkw beauty founder gave a
little speech before the movie kicked
off explaining why the project was
particularly meaningful to her okay guys
I want to welcome everyone here to the
Paw Patrol movie I'm so excited that I
get to show all my kids and all the
cousins and all my friends and everyone
my first movie
[Applause]
oh I know I have but this is different
this is like an animated movie this is
so cool I did this for you guys because
I know that how much you've always loved
Paw Patrol and I'm so excited
[Music]
hey guys
Kim posted the opening credits which
featured her name on the big screen and
once the movie started it was clear the
kids were loving it
talk a lot of trash for a dog who looks
like a toilet brush
Kim shared a snapshot of the Paw Patrol
poster featuring her character and her
name and this close-up of that giant
Dolores plushie
so cool a source recently told ET that
Kim has been spending a ton of time with
our kids since filing for divorce from
Kanye West after six years of marriage
in February having kids is just there's
no way to describe it but it's a lot
quote Kim is really going out of her way
to make sure the kids are preoccupied at
all times ensuring that they are busy
and keeping them living in the moment
foreign